(soft instrumental music)
- I'm reporting from Taiwan
where this island is increasingly
becoming a focal point
between US and China tensions.
I'm going to take you to three places
to explain how the competitions
between the two superpowers
from the tech to the military
could determine the future of this place.
But first, a little
history about why Taiwan
is so important to China.
This island was where the
Chinese Nationalist Party fled
after its military defeat at the end
of the Chinese Civil War in 1949.
(dramatic instrumental music)
Today, Taiwan holds democratic elections,
uses a different passport,
and has its own distinct flag.
And while some politicians here
support closer ties with Beijing,
many people have grown
uncomfortable with that idea.
This, our first stop, the
capital of Taiwan, Taipei.
Here growing numbers of young Taiwanese
supports closer ties with the US
over closer relations with China.
(warm instrumental music)
(woman speaking in foreign language)
- Security experts say
this kind of statement
could mean military actions
that puts the US into conflict.
And recently there has been
a lot more military activity
in the strait between the
island and Mainland China.
- This is the Strait of Taiwan.
"The Wall Street Journal" will tell you
of how many Chinese
warplanes were in the region
using information from
Taiwan's Defense Ministry
and would find that in 2020,
China sent about 380
warplanes to this region.
But this year there were
already about 290 warplanes.
(dramatic instrumental music)
US officials and former
Taiwanese military leaders
say Taiwan will need to do more
to be able to fend off
an invasion from China,
especially since China has about 100 times
as many ground force personnel as Taiwan.
China's annual military budget
is also 25 times larger.
So in an attempt to fill the gap,
last year Taiwan increased
the military spending by 10%
and has been purchasing
weapons from the US.
But some military analysts say
it's not in China's interest to attack.
The seas are rough, and Taiwan's coastline
make it difficult for a warship to land.
Most importantly, an invasion could prompt
a military response from the
US which would likely escalate.
But if not a military conflict,
Taiwan provides at least
one more area of competition
between the US and China.
Behind me is the headquarters of TSMC,
the world's largest contract chip maker.
Its chips ends up in our
smartphone and laptop,
but now because of a global chip shortage,
Taiwan is becoming more
important to the US and China.
That's because TSMC controls
more than 90% of the market
for the most advanced semiconductors.
(dramatic instrumental music)
TSMC has tried to walk the
line between China and the US,
but the tension between
these two countries
has made this difficult,
especially after Washington
restrict Chinese telecom
giants Huawei's access to TSMC
over national security concerns.
The Trump administration has
instructed American supplier
to stop working with TSMC
if it kept exporting chips to Huawei.
(dramatic instrumental music)
To reduce its dependence on Taiwan,
China has made chip
manufacturing a priority.
So has the US with a
commitment of $15 billion
to building up that sector.
- We're investing aggressively in areas
like semiconductors and batteries.
That's what they're doing
in others, so must we.
- [Joyu] But it will take years
before these efforts bear
fruit, giving the US and China
yet another reason to focus on Taiwan.
- [Christopher] Thank you.
- [Tsai] I suppose we should do this.
- [Christopher] We can do that, okay.
(woman speaking in foreign language)
And I can say with confidence
that the United States'
partnership with Taiwan
is stronger than ever.
- Ultimately, the future of this island
is going to be a key challenge
for the Biden administration.
So the US will have to
find the right balance
between supporting
Taiwan while making sure
ongoing tensions with China
doesn't escalate further.
(dramatic instrumental music)